much now
two vital calls
that uh on the situation in russia and
ukraine
the first was to a bipartisan group of
members of congress who are currently
representing the united states
along with vice president harris at the
munich
security conference
the second was the latest in a series of
calls over the past many months
with the heads of state of our nato
allies and the european union to bring
them up to date on what the united
states thinks is the current state of
affairs
and what's likely to happen in ukraine
in the coming days
to ensure that we continue to remain in
lockstep
that is the european union and nato
despite russia's efforts to divide us at
home and abroad i can affirm
that has not happened
the overwhelming message of both both
calls was one of unity determination and
resolve
i shared with all of those on the calls
what we know about a rapidly escalating
crisis in ukraine
over the last few days we've seen
reports of a major uptick in violations
of the cease-fire
by russian-backed fighters attempting to
provoke ukraine and the dambas
for example
a shelling of a ukrainian kindergarten
yesterday which russia has falsely
asserted was carried out by ukraine
we also continue to see more and more
disinformation being pushed out by to
the russian public
including russian-backed separatists
claiming that ukraine is planning to
launch a massive offensive attack in the
don boss
well look
there is simply no evidence these
assertions and a devise defies basic
logic
to believe the ukrainians would choose
this moment
with well over 150 000 troops arrayed on
its borders
to escalate a year-long conflict
russia state media also continues to
make phony allegations of a genocide
taking place in the dambas dumbass
and push fabricated claims warning about
ukraine's attack on russia without any
evidence that's just what i'm sure
ukraine's thinking of doing attacking
russia
all these are consistent with the
playbook the russians have used before
to set up a false justification to act
against ukraine
this is also in line with the pretext
scenarios that the united states and our
allies and partners have been warning
about for weeks
throughout these tense moments the
ukrainian forces have shown great
judgment and i might add restraint
they refuse to allow
the russians to bait them into war
but the fact remains russian troops
currently have ukraine surrounded from
belarus along the russian border and
with ukraine to the black sea in the
south and all of its border
you know look
we have reason to believe the russian
forces are planning to and intend to
attack ukraine in the coming week
in the coming days
we believe that they will target
ukraine's capital key
a city of 2.8 million innocent people
we're calling out russia's plans loudly
repeatedly not because we want a
conflict but because we're doing
everything in our power to remove any
reason that russia may give to justify
invading ukraine and prevent them from
moving
make no mistake
if russia pursues his plans it will be
responsible for a
catastrophic and needless war of choice
the united states and our allies are
prepared to defend every inch of nato
territory from any threat
to our collective security as well we
also will not send troops in to fight in
ukraine but we will continue to support
the ukrainian people
this past year the united states
provided a record amount of security
assistance to ukraine to bolster its
defensive
650 million dollars from javelin
missiles to ammunition
we also previously provided 500 million
dollars in ukraine and humanitarian aid
and economic support for ukraine
and earlier this week we also announced
an additional sovereign loan guarantee
of up to one billion dollars to
strengthen ukraine's economic resilience
but the bottom line is this
the united states and our allies and
partners
will support the ukrainian people
we will hold russia accountable for its
actions
the west is united and resolved we're
ready to impose severe sanctions on
russia if it further invades ukraine
but i say again russia can still choose
diplomacy
it is not too late to de-escalate and
return to the negotiating table
last night
russia agreed that secretary of state
lincoln
and foreign minister lavrov should meet
on
on february 24th
february 24th in europe
but if russia takes military action
before that date we'll be clear that
they have slammed the door shut on
diplomacy
they will have they will have chosen a
war
and they will pay a steep price for
doing so
not only from the sanctions that we and
our allies will impose on russia
but the more outrage the rest of the
world will
visit upon them
you know
for many issues to divide our nation and
our world
but standing up to russian aggression is
not one of them
the american people are united
europe is united the transatlantic
communities united our political parties
in this country are united the entire
free world is united russia has a choice
between war and all the suffering it
will bring or diplomacy that will make a
future safer for everyone now i'm happy
to take a few questions uh nancy from
bloomberg uh thank you so much sir do
you think that it is wise for president
zielinski to leave ukraine if an
invasion is as imminent as the us says
it is
that's a judgment for him to make and
the determination as to whether or not
i've spoken with zielinski
a dozen times
maybe more i don't know
and uh
and
it's uh
in in the pursuit of a diplomatic
solution
uh it may not be fault
maybe the wise choice
but it's his decision
and do you have any indication about
whether president putin has made a
decision on whether to invade do you
feel confident that he that he that
hasn't made that decision already
as of this moment i'm convinced he's
made the decision we have reason to
believe that
there seems to be a unanimity of spirit
to do between the united states and
europe to do some sanctions with the
comprehensive sanctions but are is
everyone on board with the exact same
sanctions that you want to do
uh
yes um
there will be some slight differences
but none there'll be more add-ons than
subtractions
and
president putin is going to oversee some
nuclear drills this weekend how do you
see that happening what's your reaction
to that sir thank you
well um
i don't think he is remotely
contemplating nuclear
he's using nuclear weapons
but i do think it's uh
i think he is um
focused on
trying to
convince the world that he has
the ability to change the dynamics uh in
europe
in a way that he cannot
but i i don't uh
how much of it is a uh
cover for just saying we're just doing
exercises
and and there's more than that i just
can't it's hard to read his mind
you're convinced that president putin is
going to invade ukraine is that what you
just said a few months ago
yes so is diplomacy off the table then
no
all until he does diplomacy is always a
possibility
what reason do you have to believe he's
considering that option at
all we have a significant intelligence
capability thank you very much
don't worry about it